tasha season of the bachelorette still
has so many more
shocking surprises nobody's really
feeling
confident what just happened once a
cheater always a cheater
i don't want to hurt anyone i can't
this thing could be the bomb that just
explodes everything i'm
so confused like this is really real for
me
i don't want you to be making the
biggest mistake of your life
it's just like a watch
it's like a lot and then
premiering on january 4th
an incredible new season of the bachelor
with our new bachelor matt james
love for me is about the heart
and the way that i view life everything
is a blessing
[Applause]
he's a tall dark and handsome what more
could he want 10 out of 10 he is the
perfect bachelor
he is probably the most handsome man
i've ever
seen you may be someone that i could
share my life with
i felt that instant chemistry
it's the best feeling it's like
butterflies and excitement
it just keeps getting hotter it's just
like
yum daddy i felt like we had like a real
connection a real spark
i definitely could see myself falling in
love with you
oh my gosh i am so in love with math
all my worst insecurities are coming out
i feel like i'm like losing my mind
i want to see mata this isn't easy for
anybody
it looks like you have a guilty punch
you have no class
i'm not here for the girls i'm here for
matt i just have to hope that it's worth
it
an all-new season of the bachelor
premieres january 4th